MOLLY KNIGHT RASKIN:
I just wanted
to start out by
thanking Google here
in New York for inviting
me here to speak today
about my book, which
was just published
a couple weeks ago
by Da Capo Press.
It's called "No Better
Time-- The Brief,
Remarkable Life of
Danny Lewin, the Genius
Who Transformed the Internet."
First, just a little
background about me.
I am a journalist.
I've worked in the
field since my first job
as a local radio
reporter in college.
Actually, even
earlier than that,
since my first
job as a newspaper
reporter in elementary school.
And over the past 15 years,
I've had the good fortune
to work in print, television,
and documentary film,
and often, when possible,
travel the world
in search of a good story.
And I got my real start
here in New York, actually.
I moved here right
after college.
Like a lot of idealistic,
young college graduates,
I packed up a U-Haul
with some friends
and moved here into a
tiny, cramped apartment.
And I was thinking
about it last night.
It's almost funny to
stand here today and think
how I applied for
jobs back then.
To date myself a
little bit, I applied
with paper cover letters,
which I hand-delivered
to offices all over New York.
And I followed up with
phone calls from landlines.
And that's really when I
set out on my career path
here in the city.
And at the time,
I guess, I could
say the internet was
in its-- I look at it
as its teenage years, still
finding its identity and place
in the world.
And we were all trying
to figure it out
as users and businesses
and academics and thinkers.
And I'm often
asked how I decided
to write a book about a
mathematician and computer
scientist, particularly
by those who know me well.
I didn't have any math
or science training.
I somehow, as an
English major, managed
to avoid any math and science
subjects all through college.
And I didn't pass calculus.
But the answer is really simple.
The reason I wrote
this book is because it
was a story that was
so inspiring to me,
so exciting and so captivating
that I couldn't go of it.
And that's what I'm here
to talk to you about today.
It's the story of Danny Lewin.
And of course, given the
audience here at Google,
talk a little bit also about
the innovation and the science
underlying the technology
that Danny helped create.
The story of "No Better
Time--" the subtitle of my book
is "The Brief, Remarkable Life
of Danny Lewin, the Genius Who
Transformed the Internet."
And I realize that at
a place like Google,
that's probably a
bold claim to make.
You probably have a lot
of people who you know,
or many of you may
be geniuses yourself,
and you're working to
transform the internet.
But I hope the book
makes a case for--
and I'd like to make a case
today for-- Danny Lewin's
genius, the genius of his
company, the people who
surrounded him, and the great
things they did with Akamai
Technologies, and
how it was born.
I'm just going to read you a
little bit from the preface
of the book to give you an
idea of the incredible span
of Danny's short life.
"No Better Time" is the story
of Danny Mark Lewin, who
was almost certainly the first
victim of the 9/11 attacks.
It's the story of an
extraordinarily gifted
young man who believed
that anything was possible
and let nothing
stand in his way.
Of an all-American kid who moved
to Israel against his will,
ended up falling hopelessly
in love with the country,
and served as an officer
in the most elite unit
of the Israeli army.
Of a young soldier who was
trained to hunt and kill
terrorists and who, in
a tragic twist of irony,
later died at their hands.
Of a loud, irreverent young
computer science student
who formed a
beautiful friendship
with a soft-spoken,
reserved professor.
Of a husband and
father who spent
years struggling to make ends
meet and became a billionaire
almost overnight.
Of a theoretical mathematician
who wrote a set of algorithms
that would change
the internet forever.
Until now, it's a story that
has remained largely untold.
When Danny Lewin was
alive, business journalists
categorized him and
his company, Akamai,
as breakout stars
of the dot-com boom.
After his death on 9/11,
the mainstream media
eulogized him as one of the
2,975 victims of the attacks,
but never fully
investigated his actions
on American Airlines Flight 11.
His family and friends have
remained largely silent.
They are certain that
Lewin courageously
tried to stop the terrorists,
and that he was likely
the first victim of the attacks.
But they have been
reluctant to share publicly
why they believe
this to be fact.
Some stories, I
have learned, simply
can't be told without
the passage of time.
You can dig at them, push
them, and pound the pavement
in search of ways to
bring them to life,
but you cannot be true to them
until their keepers are ready
to share a part of their lives
long shrouded in privacy.
It's not until that point
that they will reach willingly
into the wells of
their memory, perhaps
even back to those
moments hardest to relive,
and begin to tell the story.
So Danny Lewin was born in
Denver, Colorado, in 1970.
And in many ways, he had
an all-American childhood.
He was the eldest of three boys.
His parents were both
doctors, and they
lived in a very nice
suburb of Denver
called Englewood, Colorado.
He and his brothers
were athletic and smart.
And they just enjoyed a
very nice childhood there
near the mountains.
They skied and played all sorts
of sports, loved the outdoors.
But his childhood was
different for a few reasons.
And I think many of them help
explain the success he later
achieved as an academic
and entrepreneur, computer
scientist and mathematician.
First, there was the fact
that Danny's parents believed
strongly in nurturing their
children intellectually.
And they taught them all
subjects around the kitchen
table while other
children their age
were probably watching
cartoons or playing outside.
One of the stories Danny's
brothers, who still live
in Israel today and work
in business and high tech,
love to tell is the
time they were sitting
around the breakfast table,
and their father promptly
removed the cereal
box that they were all
enjoying reading the
cartoons on the back.
And he returned a few minutes
later with the cereal box.
And on it, pasted
over the cartoons,
was an article from
"Scientific American" magazine.
And that led to sort of a
family tradition of these almost
intellectual jousting
matches over the table
and around the table
where they would
speak about subjects
in math and science.
And truly, it excited them all.
Another interesting fact is
that Danny's father brought home
a home computer
very early on, when
Danny was just a young
boy, and his brothers.
And it was a
make-at-home computer.
It was an Altair.
And it was a
build-it-yourself kit.
And that was followed
by an Apple II
when Danny was only
about nine years old.
And from neighbors
of theirs, I've
learned that they were the
first family on the block
to have a home computer, and
that Danny and his brothers
taught themselves to program it.
And by about age 10, Danny was
going around the neighborhood
helping anybody
and everybody who
got a home computer to
program it and teach them
how to use it.
Then at age 14, Danny's life
took a pretty unexpected turn,
and an unwanted one for him.
He grew up in a family
of practicing Jews.
His father became increasingly
enamored with Zionist ideology,
and in 1984, a little
bit before then, decided
to uproot the family
and move to Israel.
And this was not
a popular decision
with three children in
their early teenage years.
They didn't speak Hebrew.
They didn't have any friends
and family in Israel.
And they were happy in Colorado.
So they protested.
And of all of them,
Danny, as the eldest
and perhaps most
vocal in the family,
went to Israel
kicking and screaming.
He was very unhappy.
And at first, it was
very difficult for Danny
to find his way
in a new country.
Israel in 1984 was a
difficult place to live.
The economy was in a bad place.
There was, obviously,
and still is,
the daily threat of terrorism.
And all these things
were very new to a family
from Denver, Colorado.
But they moved there.
And Danny was just too
innately bright and grounded--
and, many of his friends
say, wise beyond his years--
to rebel in the typical
teenage way, which
we don't need to
elaborate on here.
But if any of us were
rebellious teenagers,
we know some of those ways.
Instead of going
out late at night
and doing things he
shouldn't be doing,
Danny kind of rebelled
in his own way.
He didn't spend a
lot of time at home,
and he didn't speak
to his parents a lot.
But he was very
productive with his time.
And as a young teen,
he spent a lot of time
at the local
gymnasium, which was
filled with tough Israeli guys,
building his physical strength
into what his friends
called this almost
Biblical-like proportions.
By age 16, he was a spectacle
at this gym in Jerusalem,
where he was bench
pressing and weightlifting
more than guys
two times his age.
And he also managed to
sail through school.
He went to science and
technology high school
in Jerusalem.
And despite what some say was
not the most stellar attendance
record, he sailed through.
He found school very easy.
And he taught himself a lot.
He loved to read, and
loved to go to the library,
and loved computers.
And his best friend,
Marco Greenberg,
who works and lives
here now in New York,
said he remembers that it
occurred to him just how
smart Danny probably was when he
mentioned that if Danny wanted
to go to college in
the United States,
he would have to take
the SATs or the PSATs.
And Danny looked at him and
just said, I already took them.
And Marco was somewhat taken
aback, and said, really?
Well, how did you do?
And the answer, which he
said without any fanfare,
and very modestly,
was, well, perfectly,
almost perfectly on both
the English and the math.
And that just wasn't
a big deal to him.
That was the way he operated.
At age 18, like native
Israelis, there's
compulsive military service.
And Danny, as I
mentioned in the preface,
joined the Israeli
defense forces.
And much to the
surprise of anybody
who knew this bubbly, cheerful,
sometimes-all-American teenager
who was still speaking
in broken Hebrew,
there was a lot of
surprise when he
was admitted to a unit
called Sayeret Matkal, which
is the most elite
counterterrorism
unit of the Israeli
Defense Forces.
Up until the 1980s, this was
a unit that was hand-selected.
And Danny set this
goal early on of being
admitted into this unit.
And he achieved it.
And not only did he achieve
it, but he rose very quickly
to the rank of
officer in that unit.
From there, Danny went
on to the Technion
in Israel, which
I'm sure many of you
know is often called
the MIT of Israel,
the best and brightest minds
in science and engineering,
and a really wonderful place,
where everybody says Danny
really for the first time
found his intellectual haven.
He was an incredible
student there.
People today still
marvel at what
he was able to accomplish
there in just three years.
I spent some time in Haifa
researching the book.
And one of Danny's professors,
who's still there today,
said he'll never forget this
bright-eyed, excited student
crashing into his
office one day,
telling him how excited
he was about knot theory,
and how, even though
it wasn't really
a part of his curriculum,
he would absolutely
love the opportunity to work
with this professor on a paper
he was doing on
robots and knots.
And that led to the first of
many intellectual courtships
and partnerships that Danny
had in his short life.
He really became
interested at the Technion
in the hardest problems.
He was someone who
really always wanted
to take the most
challenging problems,
the problems everybody said
you can't possibly solve.
Oh, everybody's
working to solve that.
And he went straight
for them with almost
a guided-missile-like precision.
And what he was interested in
was using the highest level
of math to solve the problems.
At the Technion,
Danny juggled two
of the most difficult
degrees, computer science
and engineering, which
very few students did,
and very few still do today.
He also juggled a wife
and two young children
and a full-time job
at IBM Research Labs
in Haifa, where he
quickly stood out
among the crowd for his research
in verification processes.
And two years into his
time at the Technion,
he won Best Student Paper award.
And by 1996, he was bound
for MIT, the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
The wonderful part of
Danny's story-- and there
are many-- for me was the reason
that he decided to attend MIT.
He was accepted, after all, to
the top 10 graduate programs
in computer science in
the country, in the world.
And turns out that
there was one book
that he found in the
library that spoke to him.
And it spoke to
him so beautifully
that he decided that MIT was
the place he simply had to go.
The author of the book,
who was a professor
at MIT's Lab for Computer
Science, the legendary lab
where the internet
was, in part, born,
was a professor named
Tom Leighton, who
had been at both
Princeton and MIT
and was already a world-renowned
expert at a very young age
on algorithms and
distributed systems
and using theoretical math to
find ways to route information
through these
distributed systems.
Danny pulled this book out
of a shelf in the library.
He looked at it.
And he said to himself
and to his family,
this is the man that
I want to work with.
And this was a time before
algorithms were considered
sexy or interesting in any way.
It was still a term that
scared people in some ways
when applied to math
or computer science.
But Danny saw in Tom's work
something truly spectacular.
And more specifically, it was
that he spoke the same language
as Tom, this rarefied
abstract language
of theoretical computer science.
Tom Leighton and his
colleagues at MIT
had been working for some time
by the time Danny arrived there
at MIT on a way to end what they
had called the World Wide Wait.
I probably don't have to tell
any of you here about this.
But as a reminder-- and it's
very hard to imagine now,
at a time when we can type
anything in and have instant
gratification-- there was
this interminable wait, often,
when you logged on the
internet in the mid-'90s.
And we can all remember
that chirping, beeping,
and straining of the
modem as it connected,
and then the very frustrating,
sometimes infuriating message
you would receive that was,
please try again later.
The server is busy.
And at the time, this was
obviously a huge impediment
to the growth of the
internet, particularly
in the business community.
So at MIT, in the Lab
for Computer Science,
Tom Leighton's group was working
on using theoretical math
to solve this problem.
And Tom will say today
that nobody was really
looking at their group
for real answers.
They appreciated the
work they were doing,
but it was looked at
as kind of ivory tower
and too abstract
and too high-minded
to have any real
practical application.
And at the time,
the way people were,
as you know, trying to solve
this problem of the World Wide
Wait and problem of
congestion on the internet
was to build out their hardware,
build these huge server
farms, experiment with caching
and mirroring technology.
And all of these
worked, but they
didn't work in a way
that would survive
a huge crush of traffic.
And by the mid-'90s, we were
obviously learning this when
huge events would take place,
and everybody would try and log
on, and major
websites would crash.
So Danny joined up at MIT and,
eager to impress Professor
Leighton, started working on an
idea for his master's thesis.
At the time, he didn't
think it was a great idea.
He was, like a lot of
graduate students at such
a prestigious
academic institution,
slightly insecure
about his research.
Initially, he didn't get
great feedback on it.
But he came up with this concept
called consistent hashing,
which, as you may know, is
a method of accessing data
by assigning it a set
of unique numbers.
Hashing schemes work very well
when the number of servers
is known and fixed.
But on the internet, when the
number of servers is in flux,
it can be relatively useless.
So with this in
mind, Danny set out
to develop a new
set of algorithms
that would claim something
that no other caching
strategy could, which
was fault tolerance.
He thought the idea was OK.
But he did deep-down
believe that it
could have some
practical application,
despite the early
feedback he received.
Fortunately for him,
Tom Leighton agreed.
They spoke this same
beautiful, rarefied language
of theoretical math that
I spoke about earlier.
And when Danny took his thesis
to Tom for Tom to look at,
Tom had a bit of an
aha moment where,
as he explained it to me,
he looked at the papers.
And he saw immediately
something that he
called a gem of an algorithm,
something that he believed
actually had
practical application.
And told Danny,
this needs a name.
We need to do
something with this.
And that's how
Akamai Technologies,
the Cambridge-based company
that Tom and Danny co-founded
with two others, was born.
By 1997, they had formed
the start of a company that
promised to end the
World Wide Wait,
an audacious claim in
the mid-to-late-'90s.
And Akamai, as you
may know, exploded.
Despite the early naysayers, and
there were many-- businessmen
who called algorithms logarithms
and looked at Danny completely
perplexed when he would get up
and do his work on a whiteboard
and lay out all of
his theoretical math.
And they would sit there
scratching their heads and say,
this sounds really interesting.
But maybe you should go
back to your ivory tower
and just keep this to
your academic community,
because we've got
our own solution.
But Danny was unrelenting.
And he built a group
of people around him
at Akamai in the early days
who were also unrelenting
and believed in the
power of the business
that they were
proposing, which was
to program these servers with
intelligent software that
would effectively route traffic
around the internet in a way
that nobody had
really done before.
It was a magic layer
on the internet,
or what they called back
then, as a marketing
term, the FedEx of the Internet.
That by using Akamai's
technology, these companies
that were experiencing
crushes of traffic
could seamlessly,
effectively, and quickly
transmit information to
users, despite traffic jams.
They could circumvent
the traffic.
By 1999, the company
had exploded.
Fortunately, because of a couple
of early evangelists of Danny's
message, he won over a couple
of key people in the early days.
The stories are in the
book, but some of them
are pretty incredible.
I think by-- it was 1998, Steve
Jobs was calling and saying,
I want to buy the company.
Danny was still probably in
his MIT dorm at this point,
or maybe had just moved out.
And by 1999, just nine months
after the company was founded,
Danny, Tom, and their
co-founders and investors
took the company public
in October of 1999.
And the company became stuff
of the dot-com boom legend.
It was the breakout star.
It was the fourth most
successful or largest IPO
of the dot-com boom.
And because of this, Danny
and Tom and their colleagues
became overnight billionaires
and millionaires.
There were, of course,
others in the game
with caching and
mirroring technologies.
There were competitors
to Akamai and still are.
But the magic in
Akamai's solution,
which effectively
created this magic layer
on top of the internet,
circumventing the traffic,
could be found in Danny
and Tom's algorithms,
or what they called the secret
sauce, and they still do today.
I've been talking
a lot about my book
recently to various audiences.
And I typically don't linger too
much on the word "algorithm."
It still sort of scares people.
And within these walls, you
may find that surprising.
But if you ask 10 people on the
street, what is an algorithm,
you're likely to get some
rather bewildered looks
and some puzzling answers.
And I have to say,
I was the same
before I started
working on this book.
And here I am today at Google,
where algorithms are king.
And of course, just last
night, the very exciting news
of a new search
algorithm, one that
promises to be even more
precise and faster than the one
that we use today.
And so I had to
think last night,
when I heard that news, that
no doubt it would be something
that Danny would be
absolutely thrilled by.
Donald Knuth, who is often
called the father of computer
science, once
said, "An algorithm
must be seen to be believed."
And I love that quote.
And I think it's one of
the extraordinary things
about Danny Lewin's story.
It's that, at first,
the power and the beauty
of these algorithms were
not obvious to people.
Professors rejected them.
People in the academic
community rejected them.
One of Danny's papers
came back with a stamp
on it saying something like,
this is very interesting,
but it has no
practical application.
But those who could really
see them and understand them
and appreciate what Danny and
Tom and others were trying
to do knew that what
they had on paper,
and then in a prototype
at MIT, had the potential
to change the way
the internet worked.
Danny's story is spectacular in
many ways for all the reasons
I've talked about
up until this point.
But by this time, when
Akamai had taken off,
Danny was still in
his late 20s, the time
before most people have
achieved most of their dreams,
or any of their dreams.
And unfortunately, Danny's
story has a very sad ending,
his personal story.
On 9/11, he got on a
flight from Logan Airport
bound for Los Angeles.
It was a tough time for
Akamai, as you know.
By 2001, the bubble had burst.
And Akamai and Danny and
Tom and all of the others
who they worked
with were struggling
to keep the company afloat
in a time of a lot of change.
And they were really struggling.
And that morning, Danny
got on this flight
bound for Los Angeles.
He had made that flight
so many times that year
that he knew the flight
attendants by name.
He had his seat.
He was on his phone
making phone calls,
working up until the
minute the flight took off.
And we don't know
exactly what happened
on that flight that day.
But we do know that 14 minutes
into the flight, a hijacking
began on board.
And it began in
business class, where
Danny was seated in his
Gap jeans and T-shirt,
looking nothing like an
entrepreneur or billionaire.
And we know from the very
courageous and harrowing
recordings that the
flight attendants
transmitted to ground
control that there
was a struggle in
business class,
and that the passenger
in Danny's seat,
which was 9B in business
class, had been engaged
in a skirmish with
one of the terrorists
and had been stabbed in
the neck from behind.
Again, we don't know exactly
what happened on that flight.
But if Danny was killed
instantly, which is likely,
he would be the first victim
of the September 11 attacks.
And if, as the
evidence, I think,
strongly suggests, and also
the anecdotal evidence,
which I gathered from more than
120 interviews with his friends
and family, all of whom
said, without question,
that the moment they knew
the flight had been hijacked,
that Danny had fought back.
Danny was only 31.
He left behind a wife
and two children.
And in a very tragic
twist of irony,
that day proved so
much of what Danny
predicted for the
internet to be true.
It was the web equivalent
of the 100-year flood.
News organizations,
federal agencies,
airlines were all struggling
to keep their websites
live in a complete
crush of traffic.
Many people, myself
included, sitting at home,
trying desperately to find
out information about friends
and loved ones and
exactly what was going on.
And phone lines were down.
And it was chaos.
And at that time,
unbeknownst to anybody
that Danny was on
that flight, a lot
of these news organizations
and federal agencies
were picking up the phone to
call Akamai and ask for help.
And the company,
which was already
struggling, as I
mentioned, with the weight
of the dot-com crash, that
day lost the heart and soul
of their company and still
managed to press forward.
They say today that they
did so in Danny's name
and in his spirit, and that he
would have never, ever let them
be discouraged, consumed
by grief, or given up.
So that day, Akamai
Technologies helped
major websites stay live.
CNN, which went down
for a little bit of time
that morning, was
back up and running
that day and in
the following days,
and managing unprecedented
traffic seamlessly because
of Akamai's help.
And that's just one example.
And I think that it's really
an honor to be here today
at Google to speak about
Danny and his legacy.
Akamai Technologies,
as most of you know,
is still very much alive today.
At any given moment, the
company controls almost 30%
of the world's internet traffic.
It had offices around the
world, thousands of employees,
and is a multi-billion
dollar company today,
something Danny would
have loved to have seen.
But the honor is really that
the beauty and the inspiration
and the excitement
in the story of Danny
and what he and his
co-workers achieved at Akamai
is one that bears so many
similarities to what happened,
for example, in Menlo Park
in a garage 15 years ago
and what, as we sit here today,
is happening in dorm rooms,
laboratories, college
campuses across the country.
And it's really not just
the spirit of innovation,
but also the belief that we
can achieve something so much
greater than ourselves
and achieve something that
has a lasting impact
beyond our time.
An algorithm must be
seen to be believed.
It's no doubt that if
Danny were alive today,
you would know his name.
He would be a household name.
And more people would
know his incredible story.
But we don't have to see
the algorithms clearly
to believe that we can achieve.
It does seem somewhat
like magic, especially
to those of us with no computer
science or math to their name.
But we see the fruits and
benefits of it every day
when we log on to the internet.
And the power of
these algorithms
allow us to do so many
extraordinary things.
So again, it's an
honor to be here today.
And if you have any questions
for me about the book,
please ask.
And copies are available.
If you like what you read,
and you're excited about it,
please spread the word on social
networking, whatever you use.
And if anything today, I think
this is a wonderful place
to be and to take inspiration
from Danny's story.
He toiled away at a
cubicle, and in a dorm room,
and in a laboratory, and
in an academic setting,
for enough time to
have gotten discouraged
and to have gotten
down, and to have
moved on to something else.
But he believed.
And it's an incredible thing,
an extraordinary story,
and I hope that you enjoy it.
Thank you so much
for having me today.
[APPLAUSE]
MOLLY KNIGHT RASKIN: Does
anybody have any questions?
AUDIENCE: I actually
had a question
about-- I mean, as
best as you can tell,
was his intent when he
went to graduate school
at MIT to become an academic,
and then he sort of evolved
into this entrepreneur
because of his relationship
with his professor?
Or was that a driver
all along with him?
MOLLY KNIGHT RASKIN: That's
such a great question.
It was never a driver.
His big dream was to become a
professor like Tom Leighton,
to get his PhD at
MIT, and to become
a professor of computer
science and math.
And he dreamed of going back
to the Technion in Israel.
In fact, his professor
there really believed
that he would come
back some day.
And I think he
probably would have.
And another wonderful
part of this story
is that, as I mentioned,
Danny and others
who were studying
at MIT at the time
became very rich off
of Akamai's success.
And I set out as a
journalist sort of thinking,
oh, come on, really,
that much money?
It must have changed him.
It must have.
And the skeptic in
me really wanted
to find out what that meant
for him, because, again,
his dream was absolutely and
squarely to be an academic.
And he came to
Boston, Cambridge,
with really no other plan
other than to stand out
in the world of theoretical
math and computer science.
And Akamai was, in
some ways, an accident,
in the sense of the
business success.
I mean, if it hadn't happened
at that precise moment,
and these beautiful ideas
hadn't been given life to
by this person with
such incredible drive,
the story would have
been very different.
So really, to wrap up my
answer to your question,
I think this really
speaks for itself.
So Danny became very
rich very quickly.
He had, obviously,
very little time
to enjoy it, which is very sad.
But he didn't want to, really.
He went out and
bought a couple toys--
some motorcycles, a new house.
And then he just really
went back to work.
And when I asked his colleagues,
what did he want to do?
What was he going to do
with all that wealth?
Tom Leighton, who was
still teaching at MIT
at the time, and his
wife, who was also
a very successful professor
at MIT and world-renowned,
said, he wanted
to go back to MIT.
And before his death, he
enrolled to get his PhD.
And that was his goal, and
that's what he really wanted.
And when somebody
said to him, well,
a PhD will be easy for you.
Now you can just go back,
write up Akamai's secret sauce,
and you'll be handed your
PhD on a silver platter.
So, you know, no problem.
And he looked at them-- this was
actually Tom Leighton's wife--
and said, no way.
I have to find something
so much better.
I have to do something
totally different.
I have to change
the world again.
And that was really his goal.
And according to everybody,
he was a wonderful teacher.
And his work at
the whiteboard is
what won over so many
skeptical businessmen
and corporate
entrepreneurs at the time
when Akamai was
first taking off.
Any other questions?
Well, thank you again.
It's an honor again to be
here at Google New York
to speak to you, and I
hope you enjoy the book.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]